I get striked,
I've heard depressed people who stopped antidepressants 70 never helped in the
first place.
What do you say to that,
Mr. Peterson?
Hey,
that,
that's certainly possible.
Um,
antidepressants don't necessarily work for everyone.
My personal opinion is that antidepressants work quite well for many people
whose lives are in decent order.
So they have friends,
they have family that loved them,
they have a career,
they're educated approximately to the level of their intelligence.
They have things to look forward to,
but for some reason their mood is extremely distorted.
M and,
and negative.
And I've seen antidepressants have miraculous effects on people like that.
I think they're less likely to work when people have a plethora of life
problems,
which isn't exactly the same thing as being
depressed.
You know,
like you've been having a terrible life is not the same thing as being
depressed.
Although the two can overlap.
And it isn't obvious to me that people who,
you know,
maybe they have a drinking problem or a drug abuse problem and they're
unemployed and they have a pathological family and their friends aren't good for
them.
And,
um,
you know,
they,
they have a string of failures behind them and they don't have much to look
forward to in the future and all that.
It's,
it's a lot for an antidepressant overcome.
But under those circumstances,
maybe the antidepressants can help stave off feelings of like suicidal feelings
and that sort of thing.
But antidepressants don't work for everyone,
but some people they work really well for.
And if you're depressed,
they're definitely worth a try.
You know,
in a month if they're going to work.
Also,
there are a variety of different kinds of antidepressants and you have to figure
up dose and you have to figure out when you should take them during the day and
you,
and you have to figure out tight.
So they're,
they're not a cure or they're a tool for helping control negative emotion and
they can be very effective.
So,
but that doesn't mean that there aren't people that they didn't help.
So that's what I would say about that.